everyone this is Kevin from the chess
website comm and today we're gonna be
talking about how to attack the shallop
defense in the King's gambit if you've
been following me for any amount of time
you probably know that the King's gambit
is my favorite opening in chess
specifically the accepted line that's
we're gonna be over and that's where the
shallop defense comes from so after they
take here on f4 we play Knight to f3
Black has lots of different options but
the Shelf defense is if they play Knight
to f6 now we are gonna continue with E 5
and there's a few different plays that
I've seen from black the most common is
Knight to h5 but they could also play
Knight to e4 they could also play Knight
to d5 so in this video we're gonna be
going over how does white attack
depending on where black goes from here
the first variation that we will look at
is if the knight comes to h5 now a few
things to point out here it's very
difficult to remove this night from h5
it is doing a good job of defending this
pawn now we are gonna continue with d4
this opens up the center of the board
both of our bishops can get involved
into the game this Bishop is attacking
this pond which is generally what we're
looking to do in the King's gambit get
our light square Bishop out castle on
the Kings side capture this pawn here on
f4 at some point so the knight on age 5
is stopping one of the things that we
want to do in the King's game it but it
also takes away one of the threats and
puts it on the h-file which isn't doing
a ton so yes it's kind of a nuisance
that you can't take this pawn right away
you will be able to take it later on in
the game but the good news is this
Knight here isn't doing too much and you
kind of have free rein to attack your
opponent however you want to now from
here they have lots of different options
usually they're gonna be playing at
their pawn towards the center could be
d5 it could also be d6 if you see d5
then I would continue with E 2 getting
ready to castle to the King side this is
the general concept of the King's gambit
giving your rook here to f1 so it can
control this
semi-open file here on the Athan after
you play Bishop to e2 they have a couple
different options they could try to add
more protection here on this pawn here
on f4 and just give up their King side
protection they could look to castle on
the Queen side so with that they may
look through everything on the King side
maybe push their pawn even to g5 if
that's the case I would go ahead and
take with the knight there's usually
gonna be a lot of exchanges in this
variation that's gonna be completely
okay they take with their Queen we take
with our Bishop here on h5 they can come
down they can't take our Bishop it's
protected by the Queen but after the
Queen comes down here to g2 the Queen's
gonna come to f3 again lots of exchanges
on the board but that's what's gonna
happen sometimes in the King's game and
now if they don't bring their pawn to g5
another option would be bring your
Bishop down to g4 that's one of the
reasons that you play d5 is to get your
LightSquared Bishop out and start
attacking your opponent if this is the
case I'd go ahead and castle on the King
side of the board get that King side
safety also get this rook here on f1 to
protect this knight on f3 they have a
couple options here they could start to
bring the knight involved into the game
Knight to c6 they could play pawns who
c5 tried to attack on the King side of
the board if they play Knight to c6 I
would just go ahead and play Knight to
c3 right here the difference would be
notice that the night here on c6 is
blocking any sort of attack with Bishop
to b5 or if the Queen was here Queen to
b5 you can't check your opponent notice
how this is different is if black were
to play pawn to c5 well now we can have
the knight come back to you one kind of
looks like a strange move but it is
opening up the door for a strong attack
black pretty much needs to exchange
right here if they bring their Bishop
back then we're just going to take the
knight right here if they don't then we
can just take the bishop here on g4 so
they'll usually take here we exchange
and now we're attacking this night here
on h5 so they can't just freely take
this pond because we could just take
there
here on age five so they could decide to
bring their queen down here to h4 but
now we can bring our queen to b5 this is
check notice how this is different
because the night's not here on c6 so it
now the night's gonna come to d7 more of
a defensive stance than if it was here
on c6 and then Y can play Knight to c3
this is both attacking this pawn here on
d5 as well as the Queen attacking the
pawn here on c5 and the pawn here on b7
so all extremely good for black now if
we come back and said the Queen coming
down here to h4 maybe they play g6
trying to hold on to this Knight well
now I can get pretty aggressive and
start to push up the board with e6 this
is you know this King's no longer gonna
be casting on the Queen side of the
board putting a lot of pressure on the
opponent's here at some point can freely
get back this pawn here has to both the
bishop and the rook attacking it the
Queen in the center of the board a very
very strong attack from white if we come
back to this position instead of d5 if
you see d6
well in this case I would bring your
Bishop to c4 it's not being blocked by
the central light Square pawns right
here putting a lot of pressure on the
opponent if they try to go pretty
defensive here knowing that you're
attacking a weakened square here on f7
it's only defended by the King something
like Bishop to e7 I'm going castle on
the King side common theme in the King's
gambit maybe they Castle Knight to c3
you're gonna continue as normal
eventually you'll be able to take this
pawn here on f4 once your knight moves
then you'll have both the rook and the
bishop attacking that if they don't want
to play defensive and play Bishop e7 and
then castle on the King side maybe they
want to be pretty aggressive with Bishop
to g4 in that case I would still castle
on the King side if they were to push
with d5 I would bring the bishop back
here to b3 still controlling this long
light square diagonal I would not bring
the bishop back here to e to now instead
of moving the
central pawn on the D file if you
instead see something like pawn down to
g5 the safer move is to bring this
Knight back to d2 but we're not playing
the Kings gambit for safe we're trying
to attack and that's what this video is
about so in this case the best move
would be h4 now this is the common theme
if you haven't seen the Kings gambit the
original video I made many years ago I
definitely recommend watching that video
but the thought in here is if they want
to continue pushing here so h4 g4 then
you're gonna bring a Knight to g5 it has
an outpost here ready to attack their
opponents and they have a couple options
here one if they wanted to bring their
pawn down this opens up for the lights
for a bishop to defend this pawn on g4
which is extremely important why can
push ecigs and this is a critical move
in this opening because it stops the
bishop from defending the square right
here so if they were to take with their
bishop okay that's fine go ahead and
take with your knight they take with a
pawn I mean the Queen captures right
here on a g4 King white out in the open
attacking this night here on h5
attacking this pawn here on f4
something's got to give for black if
instead they take with their pawn first
okay well now don't worry about this
pawn but go ahead and take with your
queen right here now the knight and the
Queen are both detecting this pawn again
the Queen is attacking this night here
on h5 as well as this pawn on f4 things
are gonna go extremely well for white in
this position if they instead decide not
to bring their pawn down and leave their
light square Bishop blocked where it is
they could look at this and say yeah
I'll just go and bring my knight down
here to g3 I'm attacking the rook here
on h1 but this is a very deadly square
that the Knights here on G 5 because it
can just come up and take here on f7
after the King takes Queen takes here on
a g4 not defended by the bishop on c8
and things are just all wrong
for black there's no good square for
black to go to and if they look at and
say
yeah I'll just go ahead and gobble up as
much material as I can maybe Knight
takes on h1 this is game over this is a
forced checkmate after Bishop to c4 now
there's different iterations of where
black can go but it all ends up in a
checkmate maybe they play pawn down to
d5 you can capture with on passant here
and after a very series of moves white
is going to win this game so that's what
happens if your opponent plays that
night to h5 at the very beginning of the
game there are a couple other variations
that you'll see not extremely common but
I do want to go over some of those in
case you do come across them the first
one would be Knight to d5 this yes is
holding on to this material but it's
gonna be a little easier to kick this
Knight off than if it was over here on
h5 because you're gonna start with c4
and it doesn't matter if they come to b4
doesn't matter if they come to b6
they're usually gonna go to one of those
if for some reason they come to e7
that's an extremely strange move not a
very centralized active Knight and it's
blocking off all of the pieces that you
usually want to get involved into the
game once you bring your epon out but
let's say they come back to b6 White's
gonna play pawn d4 very common theme
what's nice about the King's gambit is
you're doing a lot of the same things
you're playing your pawn up here to d4
so that your dark square bishop can take
eventually here on f4 then you're gonna
get your light square bishop at bottom
to the game castle on the Kings side at
some point now if they come down Bishop
to b4 just play Knight to c3 stopping
the threat right here maybe they castle
on the Kings side then the bishop takes
on f4 things are gonna be completely
fine if instead of bringing the Bishop
down they want to challenge the center
of the board d6 is an option here go
ahead and take the pawn maybe they
recapture with their pawn and then you
take with your bishop that's completely
fine if they play something weird maybe
they want to challenge on the King side
with f6 I would play pawn c5 forcing the
knight to move after the knight comes to
d5 probably the the option they would go
with then at Bishop
to see for this opens up to castle on
the kingside it also puts a lot of
pressure on this king side which has
been weakened with the pond coming here
to f6 there's not a lot of great squares
for black to go
they could play c6 but this is starting
to weaken the king side or the Queen
side of the board and white can continue
to develop as they want they could take
if they want and then take this pawn
here on f4 they could castle on the King
side so White has many different options
in this example now if the knight
doesn't come to d5 at the beginning if
they just say yeah I don't even care
about protecting this pawn anymore I'm
just gonna come down to e4 pretty rare
move but you could see it I would ignore
this just just a weird move in general
and play d4 now if they play c6 I would
go and bring to just take with my bishop
here on f4 pretend like they're not even
doing anything you have your game plan
your back the material that you want and
your prepare to get your light square
bishop involved castle on the Kings side
you have a pretty strong attack if
instead maybe they play d5 try to have
an outpost here with their Knight I
would still just take with my bishop
here on f4 if they get their other
Knight involved into the game now I'd
played Bishop to b3 preparing to castle
on the King side you can see the bishop
is now attacking this as well that's why
it's gonna have a pretty good game so
that is the shallop variation in the
King's gambit gonna be going through
making a video on every single variation
that you'll see in the King's gambit I
want to make sure everyone's prepared if
you are playing it because I always
recommend players to try out the King's
game but see if you like giving up
material King game but you can generally
get that material back but you're giving
up material to have a very very strong
attack against your opponent but with
that I recognized people need to
understand all the variations you could
run into on how to attack that so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
definitely try it out let me know what
you guys think if you run into the shop
defense it's not the most common
variation by any means but every now and
then you'll run into it and hopefully
now you know exactly how to attack it
thanks again for watching I'll see you
guys in the next video